you
the Academy of Motion Picture Arts and
Sciences presents its 34th annual
Achievement Awards
this is Santa Monica California since
early morning crowds have been happening
here outside the city for an
anticipation of the ceremonies which
will begin inside shortly
you will join the members of the Academy
at the international press corps
covering this event as the motion
picture industry honors the creators of
the world's finest entertainment for you
are the guests of the Academy
from all over the world wherever motion
pictures are made people who victim have
gathered here for the Academy Awards
program which begins now with the
star-spangled banner sung by Miss Mary
Costa
a streaming
Oh
ladies and gentlemen based on
award-winning themes by Steiner Neumann
Rocha and gold arranged by Alexander
courage the Oscar fantasy overture
number one Johnny green conducting
ladies and gentlemen the president of
the Academy of Motion Picture Arts and
Sciences mr. Wendell quarry
fellow members of the Academy honored
guests and friends everywhere it is
customary at this time for the president
to bring you a message an Academy Board
of Governors tonight the message is
brief welcome all to our 34th annual
awards while we hope you will be
entertained this is primarily a news
event the course of which tomorrow's
page one headlines will be made for 34
years the academies essential purpose
has been to honor We Trust with dignity
the outstanding film achievements of the
past year the motion picture audience
throughout the world even at this moment
is rewarding in its own way the artists
and artisans who made our films with
applause laughter and above all its
attendance and ever-increasing numbers
now the men and women who created those
films meet three to reward the best in
each category for the highest accolade
our profession can bestow the Academy
Oscar over 2,500 members of the Academy
of mark secret ballots and mailed them
to the County accounting firm of Price
Waterhouse & Company there they were
tabulated and the final results compiled
by one man who is by now a familiar
figure to us all mr. bill Miller
very here's your certificate sir price
waterhouse tabulated the ballots I have
the results here in these on one thank
you bill
at this moment Bill Miller is the only
man in the world who knows the names
inside those ballots I have experience
we've learned he not only won't talk but
he is the world's best poker player
we've also learned that there's no
contest in the selection of our master
ceremonies so once again here is a
member of our community who like many of
us has a lovely family a nice home plays
a fair game of golf and manages to find
work
he's just an average citizen except that
when you add his charm his talent and
his warm heart you've got the nicest guy
in town when he managed to get back here
ladies and gentlemen mr. Bob Hope
thank you very much president rental car
and good evening ladies and gentlemen
and welcome to judgment at Santa Monica
yes here we are in Santa Monica for the
real West Side Story
that's what I like about our industry
the big moment for Hollywood movies
comes to you from Santa Monica on
television
we're located just a few feet from the
Magnificent blue Pacific in fact we left
the side door open so the cast of you
Taniya on the body could wade ashore
this is an exciting night the moment
we've all been waiting for
in just a few hours the Dodgers new ball
park will be open now this is the night
when the entire nations eyes are on
Hollywood
the Kennedys even gave their travel
agent the night off this is the 34th
Annual Academy Awards presentations for
you the Academy Awards for me shock
theater but here I am again giving out
the Oscars and smiling I'm something new
a method losing now I'm a two-time loser
this year not only wasn't I nominated on
Hollywood Boulevard they just put a
manhole cover over my star
but my agent said don't worry about not
getting an Oscar this time remember
you're still young that's the good thing
about having a 95 year old agent but
this is a wonderful friendly industry
and the lobby before the show everyone
was shaking hands and smiling and in the
few minutes the suspense will be over we
all know who to hate and the losers are
going to be good sports we know that but
just in case the applause has been
pre-recorded what a turnout everybody is
here tonight everybody except George
Scott he's sitting at home with his back
to the set
these the one person in our audience
will come back into the room for the
commercials you remember George Scott
he's the actor who said if he wins an
Oscar he's not going to accept it and
Hollywood needs more people like him
enough people refuse Oscars maybe I'll
get one he accused Hollywood of being
obsessed for the Oscars isn't that silly
I remember a couple of days last July
when nobody even mentioned it by the way
this telecast is being taped for later
showing to our actors overseas
it'll be the first time the rerun will
have a bigger audience in the original
there's a lot of pictures being made
overseas nobody reads for a pardon room
or not depends on how you react to a
typhus shot there are very few homes in
Beverly Hills that don't have someone
near and dear overseas today if you see
a star in the window it means he's not
working
they finally finished making the longest
day in France and President Kennedy is
very happy about it
he can take a firmer stand in Berlin now
the janux giving us our army back and
we're all delighted that Grace Kelly is
coming back to Hollywood from Monte
Carlo it's too bad she couldn't be here
tonight for some real gambling imagine a
princess making a picture it proves once
and for all how democratic money really
is and I'm thrilled about it we need
royalty in Hollywood
something has to stem the tide of soupy
sales it's a cultural exchange she's
coming over to make a picture for
Hitchcock and in return he's going over
there and work as a blackjack dealer
confidentially the real reason she's
coming back as Monaco needs the money
the roulette wheel is paying off it's
for the lean year for the casino Jack
Warner's stayed home but I'm sorry that
jackie gleason couldn't get out to the
coast of the awards tonight he planned
to fly but TWA couldn't get him off the
ground
Jackie's afraid of planes vice versa
but they've been notable performances
this past year Sofia Lauren was
nominated for two women and I certainly
think she is how about maximilian schell
getting nominated for judgment at
Nuremburg wonderful performance sort of
a swiss perry mason and charles boyer
may win it for his Fanny as you never
know because Stuart Whitman play the
degenerate and got nominated I make a
u-turn and get arrested but there's been
some great pictures this year there's
the hustler that's about bings
obstetrician
guns a Navarone how to win a war with
special-effects splendor in the grass
about splendor in the grass and la dolce
vita what to do until the spaghetti is
ready
West Side Story is about teenagers who
carve each other up with switchblades
it's the best musical of the year first
time I ever saw a gang Lauren came out
whistling the tunes now this past year
motion pictures got more and more mature
today children go into a theater and see
things they used to get their faces slap
for asking about the new pictures really
are adult who ever thought Tennessee
Williams would be afraid to go now you
know we may be getting too adult one
picture got the seal of approval and the
director said where we failed you know
this may be a very significant year in
motion picture history this may be the
year they finished mutiny on the bounty
just in time to stop one among the
stockholders UT on the body cost 18
million dollars to make that's over $2 a
day
they have been working quite a while on
it in fact the first hour is silent
then there's Cleopatra I know everyone
will want to see that when the sea of
life which is exciting in Egypt in those
days as it isn't Rome now mrs. stone
isn't the only one who had a Roman
spring it's the first time Cleopatra
ever went down the Nile to Las Vegas
I don't know how the picture is but I'd
like to make a deal for the outtakes
it's quite a switch is that whoever
thought the Italians would learn realism
from us and what a scene in Rome when
Spira skirts got the final figures on
the budget and stood on the steps of the
forum and shouted friends Romans
countrymen lend me
so much for my footnotes to history
let's start making the awards so I can
have some new people to be bitter about
the first envelope will be opened by two
talented stars one of the Jones girls
Carolyn and one of the two cures boys
George
a former nominee and a current one miss
Carolyn Jones and mr. George Chakiris
Yuval thank you for remembering my
nomination well losers never forget know
what award are you two going to make
documentary films yeah well I'm putting
my money on not tonight Henry
for distinctive achievements in
documentary production two features have
been nominated Legrand olimpiadas
Olympic Games 1966 T del Easter Tokyo
Nacional illusion and
lucielle el Abu sky above and mud
beneath Arthur Cohen and Renee laughs
sweet
and the winner is this yellow a lab we
sky above Anthony
allow me by accepting this Oscar to pay
tribute to the three technicians who
have died and to the eight technicians
who have been severely injured during
the production of the film which you
have just on it
thank you very much all of you
the nominees for documentary short
subjects are breaking a language barrier
united states air force cradle of genius
Jim O'Connor and Tom Hayes Carl Dido
film low ammo eat Grigio man and gray
Benedetto Benedetti project hope Frank P
beavis and the winner mr. choucas
the winner is Project Hope Frank Phoebus
members of the Academy I'm overwhelmed
and I'm very grateful and I appreciate
this honor thank you very much
you
way they handle those Italian names the
studio must be packing pizzas in the
location lunches